qu'est-ce qui se passe tout le monde va
bien ils ont reçu un appel d'après eux
il ya des problèmes chez nous d'accord
d'accord vous voulez aller jeter un oeil
ce n'est pas vraiment un temps pour
s'entraîner les filles n'ont pas des
devoirs à faire elles vont leurs devoirs
tonnes est première de sa classe tout
comme line et charbonnier pas que vous
disiez qu'on est dur avec elle vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'au lait
c'est notre boulot ne pas les laisser
traîner dans la rue
[Musique]
vous voulez qu'on parle des filles
parlant des filles on a des futurs
médecins des futurs avocats et deux
futures stars du tennis dans cette
maison tu être sincère avec vous les
chances de réussite du projet dans vont
parler sont vraiment très très faible
vous faites une belle erreur mais tant
pis pour vous
regardez les faire quelques balles
d'accord vous appelez comment déjà moi
c'est benji mois serena
alors qu'est ce que vous en dites
j'ai écrit un plan de 78 pages décrivant
leur entraînement avant qu'elle vienne
au monde
cette brillante pourquoi j'ai jamais
entendu parler d'elles elles viennent de
compton tout va bien ils ont simplement
pas l'habitude de voir des gens aussi
beaucoup
l étang du rhône dans le court
elle ferait peut-être mieux carrément
sortir du court histoire de se mettre à
l'abri il avait entre les mains le
prochain michael jordan mais non mon
frère désolé moi j'en vois deux
tu va franchir une nouvelle étape
c'est pas seulement toi que tu va
représenter tu va représenter toutes les
petites filles noires du groupe
moi je te laisserai jamais tomber je
suis sucre
ces gens n'ont jamais eu le moindre
respect pour les chars williams mais
vous ils vous respectent
tu vas entrer sur le court la tête haute
j'ai une championne et le monde entier
le sait
la créature la plus dangereuse sur cette
planète
c'est une femme qui sait réfléchir oui
papa rien n'est impossible pour elle
tu va leur montrer ce que tu as dans le
ventre
[Musique]
venus et serena
pour changer le monde
[Musique]
venus williams qui est en meilleure amie
tu as faim pour serena williams qui est
ton meilleur ami et venice ensuite été
jusque là très réduit